hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren sandra hat mir Klamotten bei Aces
bestellt ja heftige Klamotten Luca
riecht heute eine
360° Umwandlung damit du endlich besser
aussieht wir fangen an mit einem
Aufstehen Outfit also entweder zum
Schlafen gehen oder zum Aufstehen
[Musik]
nein
du siehst damit aus damit aus wie so ein
Riesenbaby Digger
eine Stunde
[Musik]
aber was gibt's denn im ersten Outfit
Null ich bin halt ein chronischer
nacktschlafer also ich habe eine
Boxershort an und das war's so deswegen
schreibt mir in die Kommentare ob ihr so
ein Pyjama anzieht oder so aber
scheint auf einmal so wieder so krass
die Sonne jetzt mein Outfit ausgesucht
dass du mal zum Date anziehen solltest
einfach
so eine coole Hose also das hier ist die
Hose
[Musik]
auch ein bisschen so du musst also nicht
bitte sei einfach
ganz oben
ich finde das sieht total cool aus
deutlich zu kurz
aus das sieht überhaupt nicht cooler
ja
findest du so schlimm ja okay die Hose
ist bisschen zu kurz hey
also die Hose ist halt deutlich zu kurz
ins Hemd ist mir ein bisschen zu dünn
aber ich würde dem ganzen tatsächlich
solide 7 von 10 geben
richtig passendes Outfit gekauft damit
du richtig cool äh zum Strand gehen
kannst oder macht so ein Beach Club für
die Frauen
das
sieht toll wo ist das sind cool du
siehst total gut aus
[Musik]
wie ein Regenbogen ganz ehrlich das ist
doch ein cooles Outfit auch mit niemals
am Strand gehen niemals
will gar nicht ja wer bin ich
wie cool oder
lustig ihr schaltet jetzt besser
so Techno Musik deswegen habe ich dir
einfach mal so ein Raver Outfit gekauft
mit einer coolen halt Mütze also das ist
halt Mütze der Tag aber so diese coolen
junge keine Ahnung was sie tragen eine
passende laserbrille zum Laser das ist
grau Laser Brille mit so Zacken sogar
hier dran ja ganz normales schwarzes
Tanktop cool Hemd Sandra wie viele
Hemden willst du noch bestellen das
sieht genauso aus wie dieses andere was
ich gerade hatte also das hier ist das
angeblich ach so coole Hemd bestellt hat
noch zum Outfit und äh hast du den
Schlaghose
was heißt das unten ist diese breit
es so habe ich mir jetzt bekommen noch
zum Outfit Schuhe nein Schuhe
[Musik]
Größe 100 also ich beweg mich jetzt
quasi gerade von Ibiza zu Berlin
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
wie fühlt sich das an
hast du Dinge
nehmen würde würde ich sagen
eine Sechs okay
ich mag diesen das erinnert mich meine
Oma
und dann auch dieses Bild
kann ich den ganzen Katalog aufmachen
also ich befinde mich ich vermisse ich
wusste nicht dass sie so breit ist wir
haben jetzt einmal Luca ein
workout-outfit mit einem Marathon ach du
scheiße also hier so ein langarm
atmungsaktives T-Shirt das ist ein
bisschen klein ne Sporthose engine
da siehst du doch wieder komplett mein
Schwanz
dran gedacht einmal noch so ein passende
Stier Mann
Leute das war echt also ganz viel
Vergnügen für euch und für mich
ähm willst du was für den Outfit
behalten
unser Sportler Luca bald auf Marathon
raus
[Musik]
willst du mich cool
ja weil Schweißband nervt
schweißbilder
was gibst du mir also ich habe halt
nicht mal Schuhe ne
e
ich bin dir dankbar dass du mir versucht
hast und das stylanderung heute hat
absolut nicht funktioniert schade ich
würde sagen wir wiederholen das in ein
paar Wochen wenn ich für dich mal ein
paar Sachen bestellen
immer das Größte was es gibt
[Musik]